-Performing "Unloyal" from
her new album, "Still Over It,"
here is Summer Walker!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I ain't takin' your...today ♪
♪ I ain't takin'
your...tomorrow ♪
♪ We can do it my way, so ♪
♪ I ain't stickin' ♪
♪ Oh, no, I ain't stickin'
'round no more ♪
♪ Since you just wanna
play with my heart and ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ I seen you with
the girl at the party ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ You think that I'm gonna
stand on by ♪
♪ And watch you waste my time ♪
♪ Boy, I am too damn fine ♪
♪ So I'm out ♪
♪ I guess I'm unloyal, baby ♪
♪ Mm ♪
♪ I guess I'm untrue ♪
♪ I'm guess I'm unloyal, baby ♪
♪ Mm ♪
♪ So call it what you want ♪
♪ I guess I'm unloyal,
baby, baby ♪
♪ I guess I'm untrue ♪
♪ I, I, I guess
I'm unloyal, baby, yeah ♪
♪ So call it what you want ♪
♪ Think I need you? ♪
♪ Boy, you funny ♪
♪ Got my own money ♪
♪ So I'mma show you ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ You think that
I'll be lonely ♪
♪ Boy, you don't know me ♪
♪♪
♪ Said you can
come and pick up your...♪
♪ Actin' like
you're payin' for...♪
-♪ No ♪
-♪ In your Bow Wow do-rag ♪
♪ Outside in your doggie bag ♪
♪ ...I am so done with that ♪
♪ Tell me, how a grown man
so childish? ♪
♪ Under Kevin Samuels'
comments ♪
♪ You think that
I'm gon' stand on by ♪
♪ And watch you waste my time ♪
♪ Boy, I am
too damn fine, baby ♪
♪ I guess I'm unloyal, baby ♪
♪ I guess I'm untrue ♪
♪ I'm guess I'm unloyal, baby ♪
♪ So call it what you want ♪
♪ I guess I'm unloyal,
baby, yeah, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Ooh, oh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]